new show clarice just premiered tonight
right here on channel 8 it is a sequel
to the psychological thriller the
silence of the lambs where the fbi
interviews a convicted murderer to help
save solve a separate crime
orcomano further explains that tactic
and also how it can impact law
enforcement
[Music]
what goes on inside the mind of a
murderer that's a question the fbi's
behavioral analysis unit has been
answering for nearly 30 years
they started off by talking to people
that were already convicted criminals
who understand
why they murdered how they murdered to
learn their tradecraft if you will
fbi las vegas special agent in charge
aaron rauf says interviewing captured
killers has also become a reliable tool
for the bureau
to track down sinister suspects our body
of knowledge continues to expand
and it allows us to be more effective
and help state and local agencies be
more effective
in the pursuit of criminals the fbi
tells me agents who interview
criminals are well prepared but
psychologists say
not everyone is immune from the mind
games even
trained professionals can get
manipulated by people with psychopathy
unlv psychology professor dr stephen
benning says people with psychopathy
which often include serial killers tend
to exploit others pain
that could even happen in conversations
with cops for some people that may lead
to a sense of fear
of feeling like the person in front of
them is this
overwhelming overpowering force but dr
benning says a majority of mental health
impacts for officers usually stem from
day-to-day activities such as canvassing
crime scenes
those details might end up creating more
of a sense of traumatic stress
for las vegas officers that's where
metro's police employee assistance
program
or peep comes in many of us have gone
through similar things
peep director annette mullen says having
six peer counselors is a way to relate
to the officer struggling
employees set the pace for their
sessions and the help is easily
accessible
it's just having that impartial person
that can listen to what's going on
that's confidential that they can talk
to that really kind of sets an employee
kind of gives them the encouragement
just to kind of breathe a little the fbi
also prides itself in its employee
assistance program
these are great counselors that
provide that outlet to safely deal with
whatever the trauma may be
so agents can continue to catch
cold-blooded killers
we want them to be healthy in their
pursuit of evil orco mana 8 news now
another question that orco asked the fbi
if these convicted killers are even
willing
to help solve crimes well the answer is
pretty interesting they often
are as either a form of redemption or
notoriety